[Music]
[Applause]
really in a nature here which is
almost intact
click n what we have here is aly kane which
grows only in regions where the air is
very pure
[Music]
2014 i was in the third year of studies
in tourism in saint-etienne in
france and then i arrived here to
do 3 months and a few of internship this is
where i discovered the profession of  guide
[Music]
when I arrived I had to
learn how to make a fire to drive a
snowmobile to make a hole in the ice
to catch fish worked with
also believes
alain petitpoisson
[Music]
it was the beginning  of my adventure here and
that was the trigger in fact I came
back every winter and between each
winter I returned to France for a
few months and I left after
finally a good start for me it's quite
difficult to create links but at the
end of  one season I created
quite strong ties with people here  and they made
me want to stay they made
me want to come back and now to
settle
when you want as europeans to
come and settle in finland it's
quite easy everything is done online these
few  clicks and it's done
I sure miss my family a
lot but hey we try to keep in
touch fairly regularly one
little thing that's still missing is
sausage and cheese
but what's great I order them
on the internet  and in a few days
you have it at home
what I really liked about being here
was being able to be outside making
a fire outside making my coffee on the
fire this white snow is
indescribable
[Music]
when I take my guests into my
nature I love to make them understand
that respect for nature
is super important they leave with
at least that in mind if one day I have
a family I would
really like that  my children are growing up
because here we learn to stretch ourselves  and
we learn to manage in
nature it's just learning to slow down
[Music]